hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and a very warm welcome to our special
first episode from the new studio on the
set you can see behind us we've done a
great interview about all things to do
with the past the present and the future
of the show including talking about our
personal lives and some of the
background to where the show comes from
including france's worst ever gig and
then at the back i heard the word yid
yid yid yid and constantin
gets a little bit emotional it was the
end of a very difficult 10 days
and i went into my room when it got
confirmed and i started crying we talk
about the lowest lows and the highest
highs in the history of the show enjoy
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm frances foster i'm constantine
kitchen and welcome to our first
interview in our brand new studio we're
going to be doing things a little bit
differently this week because what we're
going to be doing is interviewing each
other about the journey of trigonometry
indeed uh we're going to talk about
where we've come from and possibly where
we're going as well but the first thing
to say is apologies for these terrible
mustaches we are raising money for
prostate cancer uk the donation box will
be there somewhere anton will probably
get it sorted by the time this goes out
so if you can support this great cause
please do
because you know men need support
exactly particularly white men
anyway good well done
but anyway uh
i've been looking forward to this i've
been really looking forward to this
because it's a chance it's it's therapy
isn't it that's what this is yeah of
course okay mate we're both on the couch
you know it'll appeal to you because
it's free uh anyway i can't believe i
said that yeah so we still yeah i
deliberately didn't laugh to make it
awkward yeah well done thank you very
much rather like my gig on wednesday
night now uh we started trigonometry in
2018 april 2018. but
i think one of the things that people
don't really know is a lot of the
background stuff because you know we
haven't talked about it very much but
let's start with
where we were before we started the show
so you were a working comedian yes
mostly hosting shows rather than doing
sets you were doing sets as well but you
focused on hosting shows at you know
some of the best clubs in london
admittedly but you were performing there
you weren't traveling so much around the
country you weren't doing your own shows
to to your own audience would you
neither of us had at the time
um what was that like
it was on the one hand
it was quite good because
i worked really hard to get to that
point it's a comedy is fiercely
competitive it's not fair so by hook or
by crook by working really hard i got to
the point where i was playing some of
these really great clubs on a friday and
saturday night to hundreds of people
every night
i was an mc because
there was a part of it that i really
enjoyed i it's unscripted so you can be
improvisational you can have fun with
the audience no gig is ever the same uh
it meant that i didn't have to travel
but what it was effectively was a
cul-de-sac we and once in comedy once
you get pigeon as being an emcee or a
host
that's really it you just get known as
being an mc which is actually quite
narrow-minded and stupid of the industry
and the people in it because some of the
best comedians were mcs daniel kittson
is a good example of michael mcintyre
did a lot of emceeing so it it's it's at
one point ridiculous but also that's
what it was like but i also i would
argue you pigeonholed yourself
wouldn't that be fair to say because you
kept doing these mcn gigs it meant that
you didn't have time to go out and try
as much new material to play in front of
a different audience and stuff like that
so
i'd push back on that and the reason i
push back on that is because
i don't come i'm not com i don't come
from a wealthy family which means i had
to earn money i'm not saying you were
wrong to do it but you i what i mean is
i think partly the reason you ended up
in that position is you put yourself in
that position maybe for very good
reasons yeah yeah yeah look it it was
for very good reasons but the reality is
is comedy is a rich man's game
it is and people life as a regiment yeah
but you know particularly if you want to
get ahead in the comedy industry you've
got to be able to go up to edinburgh
four or five times if you want to get
noticed really you need to spend 10
grand a pop that was never an option for
me i had to earn money so but yeah there
was an element of that there was an
element of that of you know not wanting
to travel
and as a result it was a shortcut but
like all shortcuts
and ever to be leased somewhere where
you don't want to be so well there's
another part to your story because not
only were you doing you were emceeing
hosting these shows six nights a week so
you were there the whole night so
basically every night you're around
rowdy drunk people performing comedy and
then quite often you would then go and
do the radio
overnight yeah right i did talk sport
radios
so i did two overnights at talk sport
which meant
uh some days i would do a full day
teaching then i'd go and emcee a gig
sometimes mc2 gigs back to back and then
i'd go and do overnight radio till about
five in the morning right and sometimes
you'd do that and then you'd go to bed
yeah and then you'd wake up
and you'd go and teach yeah because you
were still a part-time teacher yeah yeah
i was so i'd go in and i'd teach and i
was a part-time teacher or i do bro
breakfast shows at talk radio where the
cab came at
half five quarter past five and then
you've got to be in the studio at half
six
and if you've been mc in the night
before particularly if it's rowdy you
don't get to fall asleep till about two
o'clock in the morning because you're
all adrenalined up out of your eyeballs
yeah it was you know it was relentless
but that's what you've got to do in that
industry if you want to succeed yeah
it's the only thing you just
yeah if you want to survive exactly and
and the problem with that particular
model is that
it's not sustainable you can't have a
good life your relationships suffer your
health suffers
and i remember at one point uh i got an
eczema flare-up so bad
that it looked like i i had uh like
bread blotches you know how aids
patients yeah at the end stage they used
to get something called cuddly maybe
yeah but that's what they were dark red
blotches
dark red and i remember being on the
tube because i was so
run down and tired
and there was this girl opposite me and
she was looking at me and i'm like oh
she likes me and no she was just staring
at my arm which was covered with these
red guys oh sexy he's a nice patient
yeah
and in fact
exactly and in fact it got so bad with
my eczema on my skin and i was shedding
skin so much this isn't probably what
people tuned in for that my girlfriend
said to me could you not sleep on my
side of the bed
because that's how bad my skin was so i
was really unwell
i was working frenetically
and also i was very frustrated because
you know i would go to a gig i would do
very well
but you know i was i was starting to
open for people but nobody in the
interest industry wanted to sign me no
one showed any attention whatsoever you
were never going to be on tv i was never
going to be on tv i was never going to
have an inverted commas a mainstream
career and it and it and it felt that i
why
why because i i was i was a straight
white dude in his mid-30s at that point
when the industry was all about
diversity
i was also as well didn't have didn't
share the same political views as people
in that industry you were fairly you
were fairly uh
circumspect about that at that point
yeah right you weren't expressing your
political opinions only openly i think
no i wasn't expressing my political
opinions openly but i didn't share you
know the comedy industry's hyper liberal
attitudes to culture to gender to all
these things right and what's very
interesting about that is when i was 18
19
you could say that i had liberal slash
even woke opinions but the way that the
culture shifted was in the industry
i was sort of known as a small c
conservative or a conservative all right
leaning when i've never considered
myself like that at all
and and i got really frustrated because
i saw the hypocrisy and the bias within
comedy
where people who have left-wing liberal
opinions will get platformed
will get given a chance to shine it
doesn't matter how
ridiculous these opinions are and you
can see it you know right the way
through the bbc you know frankie ball's
new world order isn't really a comedy
show it's more like a left-wing
propaganda you know fanzine that you
might find in the old school soviet
union you know with people sitting
sitting around and talking and the
comedy industry says they want diversity
they don't want diversity they want
people of all races genders and ages and
colors
to be on stage having the exact same
opinion so here you are basically in the
comedy industry in a cul-de-sac
creatively in a cul-de-sac financially
in a cul-de-sac in every way your health
is going down the toilet you you're
barely sleeping you're doing overnight
radio you're teaching uh and you're not
really in love with teaching anymore i
think at this point it's fair to say
right and then i come along
and i'm like hey let's do a podcast
that's going to get us cancelled
well here's the thing uh i originally
you said you want to do a podcast and i
was like no because i had a podcast it
didn't work out it was very good but we
weren't all different ways for a
multitude of reasons it just didn't work
well people
given that we've had nick on the show
yeah right we might say that you did a
podcast with nick dixon one of our
recent guests and it didn't work out
because creatively you just didn't joke
yeah exactly and so that happened and
then i got offered uh a podcast with
talksport we had a pilot and this is
what's interesting this is what people
don't know about radio and tv so we did
a pilot for them and the guy and the
head of talk sport went this is
brilliant this is exactly what is needed
in sports radio it's three comedians
talking about comedy this is exactly
what's needed he then gave us about a
list of 12 changes which we incorporated
we gave him another version of the pilot
and he went no i don't like it and that
was it
and that's what you're faced with in the
industry where you have great ideas and
people at the top are [ __ ] clueless
and they've got no idea now of course
there's exceptions and there's people
who have done of course there are but
there's a lot of people in that industry
both from radio bro you know all type
different types of broadcasting who
don't have a clue what they're doing
and then there was this sense of
frustration you went to me do you want
to do a podcast and i thought to myself
it's a lot of work it's a hell of a lot
of work to do a podcast it's a hell of a
lot of work to do a youtube show if
you're going to do it you've got to be
all in you've got to do it properly
you've got to be consistent you've got
to you've got to bring something new to
the table as well this is what people
don't realize when comedians release a
comedy podcast they're like oh why is no
one listening to my comedy podcast it's
funny well it may be funny but what's
different about it are you just going to
be another maker of jeans on the market
well there's loads of people who make
jeans what's different about your genes
so when we talked about trigonometry and
you were saying to me well
i think that this has got legs and
whatever else because we're talking
to people interesting people
i thought to myself actually that's
something different
that's something that people can get on
board with
and as well a watershed moment for me
was a whole brexit referendum where
brexit happened and then the next day
i saw
a whole cohort of people in my industry
who thought
who now came out and thought it was
acceptable to demonize
to mock to smear people with different
political opinions and not only that and
they would disagree with this but it's
true they found it absolutely acceptable
to be racist to
white men but particularly old white men
and they would say things like oh what
does it matter he's just an old white
man and for you that was particularly
painful because you voted remain but
your your dad who is a straight old
white man yeah presumably that's how he
identifies yeah exactly he him uh he
voted leave i think right yeah he voted
and he is not someone who is in any way
any of those things he's not racist he's
not bigoted or whatever yeah so to you
it was a very visceral reaction i think
yeah and i and my dad married a woman of
color and then
my mother who's latin america brown bird
brown bird mike [ __ ] brown [ __ ]
ethnic right i can say that she's my mum
pronouns she her and
he when it wasn't cool in the 70s when
there was no snapchat filter or you know
hashtag mixed race or whatever all of
these different things so this is not a
man who's intolerant this is a man who
doesn't like those
yeah exactly different foreigners do you
know what i mean
just doesn't like polish
exactly mike brown bird's good polls are
wrong no who just disagreed with the
politics of the european union right
yeah and which to me is a perfectly
legitimate political perspective mike
what i'm getting at with you is you're
knackered you're working overtime you're
not necessarily you've got to a decent
place but you're not going any further
yeah
uh and then you you feel out of out of
kilter with the rest of the comedy
circuit
that you're operating in which is your
world at this point right because really
when you're a comedian the way i don't
know whether it's the sort of people
that are attracted to comedy or whether
comedy makes you this way but
people won't necessarily get this but
when you are a comedian your whole life
becomes that oh and i'm sure we'll talk
about that when we talk about my
experience but you are all in all your
quote-unquote friends are in comedy your
whole life is in comedy yeah and
suddenly this world that you you've been
living in for the last 10 years it
becomes
a place that you consider intolerant
wrong in which you feel out of place
you're not necessarily feeling like
you're going anywhere and at this point
i come along and we go okay let's do
this right yeah and i don't know if you
remember this but you said when i
suggested it to you you agreed and then
the next day you called me up
and you said that you'd had a nosebleed
which again is a reflection of your
health yeah at this point right
um
and you said you know what constance
maybe you should just do this yourself
do you remember this yeah yeah because i
had a nosebleed
and it was so bad it needed my
girlfriend to
to help staunch the bleeding
because it was i was at that point i've
actually forgotten about this i was
getting regular nosebleeds at the time i
remember i took my girlfriend to the
theater as a treat for her and i had to
leave at one point because i had to go
to the bathroom because my nose was
bleeding so heavily which isn't a good
look for a man in his early to mid 30s
you know
he's getting younger by the by the
center he started off mid-thirties now
he's early
exactly he was three years ago you were
late thirties right now i wasn't i was
anyway right so your health wasn't great
and you called me up and you were like
you know what
i'm not sure i can do this
and it's because it's capacity i just
didn't have any capacity i know i know i
just didn't have the capacity for
something new for a new project for
wanting to take something on like this
and you were and you were like and you
were said to me okay that's cool go away
and think about it and i remember
speaking to my girlfriend at the time
bless her a lovely person and she said
to me
you know i like constantine steak uh
i think you should do this and i think
it would be good for you and from then
when we started doing it
i remember our first interview we got
some great advice actually from simon
cain he was a big fan of the show uh he
was a podcaster himself he said to us
record
a a dummy episode essentially yeah so we
got finn taylor and he was a marvelous
comedian we sat down we talked
and then you because and it all it
looked terrible it sounded so everything
about it was terrible yeah everything
about it was [ __ ] and we couldn't put it
out no we couldn't put it out
but i remember the conversation being
quite interesting yeah the conversation
wasn't interesting yeah and then but you
i was like is this oh is this good and
you were like no visually because you
were very much a child of reuben and
rogan you're like no we have to change
this it has to look good it has to look
professional see i i've never really
consumed youtube in any shape or form at
that point i just didn't have the time
and that wasn't my world
and you're like no we have to do this
now maybe you're banging on about lapel
mics what's up what i don't understand
why why can't we just have microphones
you know when you when we go and do
radio that's that's how it was how is
this different to radio
and that's where the journey started and
and from then on in it's and we'll go
into it more it's it's just been an
absolute roller coaster of things that
are really bizarre and surreal from you
appearing well
hold off on that yeah we'll get to the
later bits first
uh
let me talk about uh my st my situation
before leading into it so i started
doing comedy around
mid 2015
2015. uh i did like a short course yeah
about how to write jokes and stuff and
then i started doing it and i i think
towards probably about
2016 2017 i started watching a lot of
reuben
rogan and just i became aware
politically that something was happening
and i remember and this will this will
sound really odd because i voted romaine
and because we're good people because
we're you know that that used to be the
joke that we used to make three years
ago may keep up with the material but uh
i
so i still had that very liberal mindset
in many ways and i still do to this day
you know i i'm genuinely a liberal yeah
in the traditional sense of it but
i remember during the run-up to the
brexit referendum
i probably watched
and a lot of people who hate us are
going to take this bit and run with it i
probably watched every single speech
that nigel farage gave
in the lead up to that campaign
because i think at some level i was
already starting to realize
that there was a piece missing in my
picture of the world
and i've always been someone who's very
curious about
life and politics in the world and i'm i
was trying to get to what the truth is
even if it doesn't necessarily accord
with what i already believed so i
started watching it and the more i did
you know and i was terrified of this i
was terrified of of what i was going
through because i remember i watched
dave rubin for two years before i
clicked subscribe on his youtube channel
why because i was afraid of what other
comedians would yeah if if they knew
if i liked his facebook page if they saw
that that's how the comedy industry
works yeah everybody's watching
everybody and you're worried about the
repercussions so at that point
i was terrified just to admit that i'm
looking at something the wrong thing
thing you know
uh but my life at that point was
probably as as hard as yours i was
i was working in some ways eve i was
gonna say even harder it's not fair to
say that even harder but i was doing
other things that made my life harder
which is you were gigging mainly in
london
i was not living in london and i would
be gigging in london and elsewhere so my
typical day before trigonometry would be
do a full day of work because i was not
making enough money
to to live off because it takes years in
comedy to get to that point i'd do a
full day of work
jump in the car drive for two hours
do five minutes or ten minutes at some
shitty gig with two people in the
audience drive home for two hours get
home from midnight you can't sleep
because your adrenaline is you know
keeping you awake you you eat some [ __ ]
right you go to bed at two wake up at 11
feeling like you've been smashed in the
head with a mallet all night
right and then go again
what was your worst ever gig
see it's interesting because
i don't really remember
these bad gigs because i'll be honest
with you and we'll get to it later even
when our life was starting to really get
good in many ways you know the bit i
really remember was not a bad gig it was
a great moment in my life which when i
you know jumping ahead a little bit when
trigonometry was going well my contract
situation had already happened and i was
opening for jeff norco who's since
become a good friend and he was always
very supportive to me and you know for
for people who are not aware at this
point for me opening for jeff
was like a huge opportunity of course it
was right and so and other things were
already happening and trigonometry was
doing well and this was the day when i
opened for jeff two nights in a row this
is incredible right so what happened was
we did two recordings in london
then i drove to bristol and opened for
gig for jeff at my old school theater in
my in my school that was a great moment
for me stayed the night in bristol next
day drive to plymouth which is another
three hours drive
do a gig for him there leave it as soon
as i've done my spot drive back to
london for three and a half hours i get
to my mate's house so i haven't seen for
a year he allowed me to stay with him
probably around 1am
he's already in bed so is his missus i
go to bed i wake up at 6 00 a.m so five
hours later don't see my mate that i'm
staying with either and i go to the
battle of ideas the next day right and
that that to me was a really exciting
weekend that was success that was
success but that was worse than any gig
that i've i've died at because the the
the emotional and physical toll that
that takes on you imagine that driving
eight hours in the space of two days
doing two gigs and getting about i don't
know five six hours sleep a night you
know and that was the pinnacle of my
career at the time it was success yeah
so to me you know some people not
laughing or someone tickling me that was
nothing as bad as what i was doing to
myself
you know
every day you know so i don't really
i you know maybe it's because i haven't
done comedy for a while as well like
it's the the memory of those [ __ ] gigs
that i used to do it really doesn't
exist for me in the same way what i
remember is driving myself to the brink
of exhaustion
just doing the show and trying to make
it work and you know always trying to
improve and the gigs and this and the
that you know that that was the the
thing that was actually the worst in
many ways you know
um
what about you
i mean my worst ever gig this this is a
this is a story
this is a beautiful story
so uh my tenth gig i did at the local
pub it was it was known as the grove in
south wimbledon it was my local pub it
was rough i got my first pint ever
served to me there whilst dressed in my
dad's leather jacket okay 16 years old
feeling incredible legend exactly we
went in i did it i did a i did a gig
there it was a 10 minute open spot in
the middle and i got up
and because it was my local pub because
of the people were people that i grew up
with i knew who they were there was you
know
south london me you know mixed crowd you
know working class irish blah blah blah
i was like i've got this and i riffed i
read for 10 minutes and i smashed it and
i came off and i was just like i'm a
genius and the promoter saw me and went
that was brilliant he goes you need to
do bigger gigs he goes how long have you
been going i went i've done 10 gigs he
was then he looked to me and was like
wow this is almost like a prodigy you're
gonna do this gig i'm like great he goes
it's in the lava lounge in bournemouth
so for our non-british viewers the
bournemouth is is a sort of party town
where a lot of uh what we call hen
nights and stag nights which is a
bachelorette and bachelor parties go to
right yeah exactly so guys this is what
you see
yeah yeah the lava lounge and to me i'm
like great
300 people in this place this is going
to be amazing i drove down with the
comedians uh one of whom is actually a
guy called kevin shepard lovely guy and
he was talking to me
and
i noticed that kevin kev showed a little
a few signs of trepidation he wasn't
looking that comfortable and i'm like oh
what's going on he was like he was going
to me
it's this isn't an easy gig francis i'm
like i'll be fine mate just did 10
minutes to 30 people in a pub and i
smashed it 300 it's gonna be 10 times
better
anyway we got to the we got to the gig
kevin went on uh the emcee went on did
okay
kevin went on opened did okay there was
a break i remember looking out and there
was
300 people
there was about
and they're all staggering hence so
there were
288 stags
and 12 heads and i immediately thought
this is creating an atmosphere yeah and
it's not a pleasant one no i basically
this is my crowd
so anyway they brought me to the stage
and i went on and they looked at me and
i looked at them and i realized they
weren't really on board
and uh i said my first joke and it got
polite laughter i said my second joke
and he didn't get much
and then all of a sudden i heard this
low rumble of discontent this booing
this boo this book and i went stop st
and i said to them stop stop don't boo
no no not a good move
not a power move
please don't boo let me tell my next
joke
so just imagine the scene right
it's a nightclub in bournemouth 300
staggering heads and there's these very
angry drunk men dressed in mankinis
looking at me and people coked out of
their eyeballs whilst dressed as
spider-man getting more and more angry
and i went and and and i had a little
set up and i went so i looked jewish and
then at the back i heard the word
yid
yid yid yid until 300 people were all
there chanting the word yid now i don't
know if you've ever had a very angry man
who's morbidly obese in a mankini chant
the word yid at you
but it's an interesting way to spend an
evening the funniest thing about that is
you're not even jewish yeah i'm not even
jewish but i've been anti-semitically
heckled off the stage
so i was just getting heckled booze your
[ __ ] get off [ __ ] you spurs and [ __ ] i
don't even support spurs
the tottenham hotspur right
so i put the mic back and then i walked
off utterly devastated i feel you as my
whole world was collapsing around me and
my this was my 11th gig and then i
walked up onto i walked up to the green
room
and the mc who's a guy called james
redmond who was very big he was a
heartthrob in soaps about 10 years
before that he played finn in hollyoaks
he just came up to me and he just held
me as i was just shaking in the green
room just literally convulsing with just
shock and just
sadness as this just shame and overcame
my body and i remember thinking at the
time going there's a lot of women who i
went to school with who would pay a lot
of money for this moment i just remember
thinking that and then this was the
worst bit the headliner is called terry
alderton he's a very good comedian
brilliant brilliant impressionist went
on
and did 10 a 10 minute impersonation of
me
on stage
and all i could hear backstage was the
words please let me tell my joke
i mean he was not being a dick he had to
do that yeah that's the only way you
address that situation but for you it
would have been bad yeah and he took the
roof off yeah of course and then and
then seeing that and everything that
happened and i remember bless him he
came up to me and he put his hands round
my face and went
i'm sorry i had to do that that was the
only way i was going to get them back it
happens to everyone you're going to be
fine
go to bed do a gig tomorrow you'll be
grand and bless him for saying that
buddy i know but he had to do that but
it's yeah you reminded me of a gig that
you know what my worst gig is a gig i
didn't even do really yeah did you
remember there was a there's a guy uh i
won't name names because there's no
point but there's a guy who used to run
open mic type gigs in london uh and i
turned up uh and it just looked like a
cafe there was no stage there was no
microphone oh yeah and there was no
audience yeah and i turned up and i went
hey and i always you know from the very
beginning i always tried to be
professional so i turned up but you know
uh i was like hey how are you doing nice
to meet you i'm constantine so i'm
looking forward to this gig and he
looked at me and went
it's good that you're enthusiastic
but can you go outside and see if anyone
wants to watch the show
and i looked around i looked at the
situation i walked outside and i just
got in my car and drove away
and you know what that's the smartest
thing you've ever done i know man i know
um so that was the world we were coming
from
and then we start trigonometry
and
at the beginning we it was funny because
because you said to me uh constantine i
think we're going to need a producer
and i said what for
like that's how little i know i was just
like well you get a camera you got
microphone and you just you know i had
no idea what to do and neither did you
neither of us did so uh anton who is our
producer
uh wasn't around at this time we we
we'll get to how we got we've got anton
on board but i mean he was around but we
just didn't yeah we just didn't know him
exactly thankfully
so we started with we borrowed a camera
off of
one of your mates
yes we did we borrowed a camera off one
of my mates we borrowed my wife's camera
yeah that she had yeah uh and we bought
some shitty table top microphones for
like 20 quidditch yeah right
um and we hired this like
18 or 19 year old girl yeah who was a
producer for us who didn't know what she
was doing either no either just like us
and one of the first episodes we
recorded was with pippa malgram who's
still to this day one of our great
guests
but
because of of everyone not knowing what
to do we lost most of that episode yeah
do you remember that yes i do remember
that um and that was the level at which
we were operating at the time and i was
scrumping and scraping to get guests
because i had a few contacts
um
and we just started doing it yeah
and we just started doing it in addition
to all the stuff that we just talked
about yeah you were still doing them
seeing and the radio and the teaching
yeah i was still doing all the gigs and
all this other [ __ ] and we've now added
this new podcast that we have no idea
what to do with to the list of things we
were both in relationships long-term
relationships so we were trying to keep
those afford as well and we didn't and
we were putting our money into it and we
had no money yeah i certainly had no
money yeah so we were literally putting
money that i couldn't afford into this
thing and look the comedy club that i
was working at the time very graciously
and very generously donated their space
yeah yeah i mean
yeah so we were very lucky with that
because
without that i'm not sure how we would
have started but anyway so we so we
started off the first episode is gideon
rackman
so gideon came in god bless him he was
great he was great he comes in sits down
we're around this table where you can't
see our faces yeah it's from the side it
looks like a seance yeah it looks like
it sounds terribly lit uh blah blah blah
we start recording within about i don't
know a couple of minutes
there's a horn beeping outside yeah and
it's ridiculously loud yeah so i'm like
all pumped up i go outside to see to
deal with it and there's a woman
trying to attach one of those like
anti-theft devices to the steering wheel
and in the process she keeps pressing on
the on the thing right and i go up to in
my opinion quite politely and go hey
excuse me uh are you going to be much
longer because we're recording a podcast
next door and she gets very angry with
me yeah and at this point two other
people who turn out to be her parents
come out of the house and they like
their experiences i'm harassing their
daughter
so they basically chase me down the
street
and it turned out they'd just come from
a funeral so they weren't understandably
quite upset yeah and then um we had to
write a letter of apology and give them
chocolates and give them chocolates and
that's how the show started that was day
one yeah we were already pissing people
off yeah from day one inadvertently but
still pissing people off
and then we we got we we started to
thanks to you we got some you know
really good guessing so pippa came in
although we lost that
andrew doyle came in yeah that wasn't
thanks to me actually you got andrew
doyle in did i guarantee well we wanted
to get andrew in and you were the one
that had his details somehow and as we
talked about the live show with andrew
uh a couple of months ago uh he thought
we were trying to stitch him up because
he didn't know us at the time right so
we get doily and we get gideon in we get
pipper in we get liam halligan and i had
to work really hard to get liam in you
know we got david pillingham david
pilling was great and and gradually we
start doing stuff and and you know peter
tatchell came in yeah he did you know
that that was a big guest at the time
for us um and then um all of that's
happening
and then
our producer says you know what i really
don't want to do this yeah this was like
five episodes in or something yeah she
was like you know what
this isn't for me i don't really enjoy
this kudos to her instead of you know
being you know because she was only 19
but she uh you know she she had the the
stuff to come up to us i was going to
say cojones wrong way of saying that she
had the stuff to come up to us and say
look this isn't for me so like okay yeah
but what the one thing i do remember
about that is in the last episode we
ever recorded with her
she so didn't give a [ __ ] that she was
sitting in the corner just typing and i
remember sitting there seething at the
fact that we were still paying her
and instead of paying attention to the
episode she was just like doing admin
and i could hear the keys and every time
she pressed the key i was like
really i i don't even remember that what
episode was that with
would it be jeremy shapiro maybe oh
mostly jeremy shapiro it might have been
i don't remember but my point is like it
was not a good situation no no so now
having just started and just got the
ball rolling our producer basically says
i don't want to work with you anymore
so then we found another producer who
you'd worked with before yep and he
had a studio
that was professional and he had uh the
right his cameras are probably more
expensive than the ones we used to this
day yeah right great cameras yeah he was
very skilled in terms of you know
technically he knew what he was doing
and we were like well look we can
it's embarrassing but we'll let look we
can we can maybe afford to pay you 500
pounds a month to edit four episodes
yeah
and record which is really ridiculous
money yeah you know and he was doing it
you know on the promise that it might
one day become something yeah so we go
there yeah and that's where the show
really starts taking off because we get
sargon in yeah we get diana fleischman
in we get dr linda papadopoulos in yeah
we got we get brendan o'neil
brendan claire fox yeah
eric kaufman david goodhart yeah and
matt goodwin matt goodwin uh [ __ ]
hell he's a great guest yeah like if we
got a lineup like that this month we'd
be really pleased with yeah that's an
incredible lineup and bear in mind i
remember when i read about eric kaufman
because i read him and then i
recommended him to you and say look we
need to get this guy in this guy's
talking
you know these were guys on the fringes
particularly like i mean you on the
fringes they're far more well known now
yeah but matt goodwin and we made them
yeah we made them exactly uh but all
these people know they weren't really in
in the cultural war as it were no well
sargon won sargon was and so was brenda
o'neil but the rest of them you know
really weren't yeah and then we brought
them in and then we had a conversation
and
you could feel something was starting to
happen ella wienen ella whelan yeah abs
tom slater tom slater you know we've got
a lot of the spiked green at that time
and they were great they were great they
were really good and you know at the
time i think one of the things that i
remember as well is almost all of them
said
i really enjoyed that that was great
questions yeah
and and i was almost slightly shocked
because we were very new to doing it you
know and let's be honest as well i think
if you don't mind me saying you in
particular me i was probably further
down the red pill rabbit hole at this
point you were quite scared of times
like when we interviewed sargon i
remember sitting next to you and i could
feel the fear coming off you because you
were uncomfortable oh absolutely i was
very uncomfortable talking to sargon
because i don't like him
i'm joking carl i like you very much no
it's um the reason was is because coal
to me was dangerous
coal could end my career
there are people who still dislike
trigonometry and me because we
interviewed carl i don't care anymore
they can have their opinion whatever
they're entitled to it yeah but i was
genuinely terrified okay andrews
yeah we had k anderson yeah and it was a
brilliant interview it's a great
interview so this is the point where the
show is actually starting to take off
and i think one of the last interviews
we did was actually with jeff norco it
was it was it was the last one we
recorded in that studio nicholas gruen
as well we had in there yeah and the
reason i say the last interview
because
as we were stop really starting to do
well
it became very clear that our producer
again was not on board with what we were
doing to the point where
when we
and he's a lovely guy bless him but when
we interviewed kate andrews i remember
after the interview was finished
uh he cornered her and started
explaining to her why she was wrong
about everything
do you remember and bear with me yeah i
do remember and bear in mind actually
the
the that guy the producer um who i've
still got a lot of love for and i'm
still in contact with he's a very very
intelligent guy with you know very
strong opinions of the world
but i don't think he understood like
because he was also in really great we
always get producers are in great shape
don't we just muscly men oh yeah that he
didn't really understand that a muscly
dude cornering a little woman and
basically so you're wrong you're wrong
about this might be a bit intimidating
and i remember that because kate then
went well i'm going to leave now and
then she walked downstairs and she
literally ran out the door yeah and
that's the last time i've ever seen kate
yeah so that was part of it so he
clearly wasn't aligned and i think
because he wasn't aligned it meant that
he was starting to
you know not take it quite seriously as
we'd hoped and look
it was unfair of us to expect him to be
doing a super professional job when
we're paying him peanuts yeah but that
was all that we could afford to pay him
but at the same time he was starting to
get to a point where it was unworkable
yeah and i think in characteristic kk
style i exploded at one point and i went
look this isn't working you know when
are you gonna do this and he didn't like
that and basically we went from oh the
show's taking off too we've lost our
studio we've lost our equipment and
we've lost our producer and we're back
to zero i remember because it happened
over peter hitchens because pete was
meant to came in and he recently booked
peter and he cancelled the producer
cancelled on us and peter was the
biggest guest probably to that point
that we could do of course and it you
worked really hard to be fairly to get
peter on yeah and you know
because look to be fair to peter he
didn't know who we were he had a
reputation to protect so he was very
cagey about coming on understandably so
i knew that it was unsustainable but in
my mind i'm like we just need to bank
episodes we're going we're on a roll we
need to bank episodes we need to bank
episodes we need to bank episodes
and then we'll be able to move yeah yeah
my socially conservative yeah let's get
all the points i just couldn't hold it
in that video yeah and it's just getting
too much for me yeah let's keep
everything let's make before we make the
move then you explode it and i'm like
well we've got three episodes and
and i remember just being there going
how are we gonna get out of this one
and then what we did is we went back to
the comedy no
no didn't we what about monero
of course
so what we did is we had a mate of of
mine at the time who had a house
actually around the corner from that
studio and we used his house to re a
lovely house to record an episode with
monero which at the time we were very
happy about but also uh
it was like
just in a random room in his house and
there was like a helicopter flying
overhead do you remember that yeah but
and and at the time it didn't do
particularly well that episode it did
all right it's like 12 12 000 views i
remember it yeah it's now on over 100 i
think because munira has since been a
bit of a public figure and there's been
controversy involving her so we recorded
one episode in someone's house and we
realized that wasn't going to work so we
went back to the comedy club where we
were before and in that process we
started looking for a new producer yeah
we did
and this is where talk radio came in
because
i had a producer talk radio who was
really good to me and a super lovely guy
called andrew andrew spence
and i contacted andrew and i said to him
andrew
we need to find a producer
and he goes
i think i've got the guy for you
and i went and he went and what's his
name he went anton i remember thinking
it's a bit of a weird name
right and he goes
telling me what i thought he goes but i
think that he'd be perfect for you
i was like okay brilliant
so we went to meet him
in a burger restaurant he did yeah and
so we went to we didn't know he was
vegetarian at the time now to be fair to
us when we found out we still kept
taking him out
we took him to a steak restaurant right
now you've got to look after him yeah
exactly
get some protein here yeah and spoke to
him whilst literally eating animal in
front of him
but here's the thing
right
so we made it this is the end of 2018 by
the way this is all of this so far has
happened in the space of about six
months yeah
six months in six months we've lost two
studios and two producers yeah
and then we met anton yeah and then
we we
we were both really taken with him we're
both really taken we and we were saying
look
i think this is the final part and by
the way i think he was taken with us
because by this point i was
absolutely i wasn't convinced i wasn't
certain i was just i just knew
i knew and i always said this to you if
the two of us
stick together and we we don't ever fall
out between us all the stuff this will
be a success yeah and i think it's fair
to say that i sold you on that as well
anton right
yeah because i knew i knew this was
going to work by that point i knew
because i just thought look at how
little we have yeah we have focal we
have two comedians who don't have any
profile at all no equipment no no
nothing no studio no money no money well
negative money yeah right
and yet it's working yeah i just knew it
was going to work so we get anton on
board
and we just about start the process
again we offered him the same 500 quid a
month
uh and he was working a bunch of
different jobs at the time and and doing
all that
and this is the point where my contract
happens
the very end of 2018
right we've just moved to the new studio
we've just got our feet under the table
and then
for people who are new to the show i get
offered to do this gig for charity at
one of them awoke woke us colleges
in this country
and they say that they have a zero
tolerance policy on racism sexism
classes majors and ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobic xenophobia etc
and i turn it down and i tweet about it
and a couple of our guests retweet her
and then it goes super viral
super viral it goes all around the world
this is the thing i always say about it
it was the second biggest story on the
bbc
on the day that theresa may the then
prime minister of this country was
nearly removed from office by her own
party
i remember that
and the story about some unknown
comedian turning down some shitty unpaid
gig from some stupid college was the
number two story wow in the country at
the time and i was getting messages from
all over the world
and that was an insane experience from
someone who was not in any way a public
figure at the time
because
i i don't think many people ever had
this experience but you basically you
can't sleep yeah
you're getting hundreds of messages
every day
you wake up at six in the morning and
you and your twitter dms you had a
thousand people on twitter yesterday and
now it's just like
thousands of people following you every
few hours
and you're getting like messages from
the today program times sunday times
telegraph spectator guardian whatever
you're getting phone calls suddenly
people know your phone number you know
and it's just non-stop and it was like
that for about a week and a half yeah
until eventually i got a call from uh my
agent which i luckily had an agent at
the time
to manage all of this craziness and she
said
good morning britain want you to come on
and talk about this and it's funny to me
to talk about it now because today
like i get a message from good morning
britain every few weeks now saying do
you want to come on and talk about this
or that and i
i sometimes don't even answer anymore
i'm just not interested
but then i remember when he got
confirmed
it was the end of a very difficult 10
days
and i went into my room when it got
confirmed and i started crying
it's the last time i've cried i think
because
you know all of that stuff that we've
been talking about and the things i've
been feeling about the importance of
freedom of expression the fact that
society is going in the wrong direction
i was talking about all of this and the
world around me the comedy industry the
people were around
they they were they were saying oh this
is all [ __ ] you're just making this
up none of this is true you know and i
felt you know i hate to use this term
but i felt very gaslit
by
the entirety of my surroundings and i
remember
my wife came in and
saw me crying and she's you know i just
i it was that ten days of
just this endless
stream of whatever that was happening
the stress the tension the worries
whatever and plus that feeling of
vindication
that's what it was i just felt like
finally
the this
idea that i had in my head it's it's not
just me being deluded
you know i'm actually people are
recognizing the truth and what i've been
talking about
and
then i went on good morning britain the
next day and it's a weird experience
because
they book your hotel in central london
they get you a taxi they drive you over
you turn up
and you get to this posh hotel you know
and really you want to be you know you
have a have a meal have a glass of wine
go to bed wake up fresh the next morning
but you can't
because your brain is racing so all that
happens is you're lying there all night
and you're just
all of the [ __ ] it's just running in
your head like you just over and over
and over and over and you're rehearsing
you're thinking what am i gonna say and
what if this and what if that and what
if that
and
well i hate going back to that interview
that i that my first time in good
morning britain because
it's i come across very angry
and and i did and i was very angry
because
it was that vindication plus rebecca
reed who i'm actually quite good friends
with since but you know she opened it by
completely misrepresenting what had
happened and saying that these students
thought i wasn't funny when actually
they just they had nothing to they
thought i was funny and that's why
anyway long story short so i'm not
well that i did as well as i could have
done
but i'm really not very proud of it
uh because i feel like i don't come
across well in that you know but that
was a huge moment for the show yeah it
was it was it changed the show and then
you went on tucker yeah yeah and i
remember aleister williams who is now a
he was a former guest i was a brilliant
brilliant comedian alistair going to me
it's so exciting that constantine's on
tucker carlson except do you know who
tucker was at this no i didn't know i
didn't know i didn't i didn't
it was so removed from the realms of
what i knew
and my life that i couldn't really
process it
and the thought of you being on tucker
carlson it didn't mean anything to me he
was just going i can't believe he's on
tucker
i can't believe he's on take a shower in
america yeah and also
i didn't know what you were going
through at the time i just didn't know i
didn't know you know the the the abs the
storm and until ext i've never
experienced that
i've experienced some parts of it
to a very very minor degree but i've
never experienced
that type of thing and then the reaction
that the comedy industry had to you know
that was the shock to me yeah and that
was the biggest shock to me because and
you're going to laugh very hard but i
was so naive
when i turned down that contract i
actually i mean it's ridiculous how
naive it now sounds but i thought
i was taking one for the team
i thought i was
speaking out for team comedy
that's what i thought
that's what i thought i thought this is
this is what all comedians can get
behind
you know the idea that we should be able
to do jokes on stage and the only
censors are ourselves and the audience
i thought i'm standing up
for us
for us the comedy world that's what i
thought
and what i quickly realized is actually
most of the comedy circuit
hated me for it
they hated me for standing up for free
speech in comedy
maybe not most
i wouldn't say most a lot a lot of
people a lot a very vocal and powerful
minority yeah i would say but but but
they're so powerful that they might as
well be the majority because they're all
the tv commissioners they're all the you
know you know of course of course
they're all the people who run edinburgh
they're all the people who control
everything right
so
that was one one of the reasons that i i
was crying before going on gnb because i
didn't expect that no i i thought well i
first of all i never expected it to go
viral in the first place but when it did
i was like well great i've done
something good for the comedy world yeah
for the comedy industry
and then to see the comedy industry
actually be angered by this and
misrepresent you and misrepresent me and
actually you know what i think probably
quite a lot of it was just jealousy
completely quite a lot was just jealousy
but i think also a big part of it was
ideological too which is i'd done the
wrong thing you know comedians are not
supposed to be about free speech we're
supposed to be about avoiding hurting
people's feelings
and that was a shock which is why
no matter what someone's political
beliefs are i always have a tremendous
amount of empathy
for people who find themselves going
from obscurity to being in the public
eye in that way
i don't care who you are i am one of the
most mentally resilient people on i
would say on this planet genuinely
i am
i've been through a lot and i've learned
a lot and i've done a lot of personal
development stuff i'm very mentally
resilient i don't care who you are that
is difficult it is very difficult
and there will be people who can't who
can't handle it yeah you know they just
can't so when i see people being
demonized or
or treated in this way even when they've
done something wrong in the public eye
there's a lot a lot of me that i just
feel empathy for them because i know how
difficult that is yeah and you you you
stop
what happens and this is something that
i've experienced is that you become a
public figure and you're not
constantine anymore you're constantly
kissing and you're a public figure and
then you become a public figure for
people to comment criticize but it's not
really you no it's not you they're
criticizing a
construction an image yeah an avatar
and it's it's very surreal and very
bizarre
and i remember
watching you go through that
and and also feeling that there wasn't
i didn't know what el what i could do
or what i could say well you were very
supportive actually was i yeah you were
great you were great you and i think um
i hope you won't mind me saying this but
simon brodkin who's lee nelson yeah and
i don't think he was because he was
necessarily ideologically aligned with
trigonometry i don't think he is uh it's
just him and i had gigged the week
before and he really liked me yeah and
he thought i was good
and he's a very famous comedian so at
the time for him to reach out to me he
spent hours on the phone with me yeah
just like reassuring me and consoling me
and i got you know i won't name all the
names there was a lot of famous comics
that got in touch with me and and we're
like keeping my spirits up and yeah you
know but yeah your support and the
support of a lot of other people really
there were there were lots of people
also who were very supportive i
shouldn't shouldn't lose lose track of
that you know and simon in particular
was really really great
but anyway that obviously gave the show
a big boost yep
and we went this is the very end of 2018
and then
at this point
i think we were starting to get to a
point where i think we'd started a
patreon when we got kicked out of when
we left our previous studio
and people started supporting us and uh
our first like this was the first time
we'd ever actually
not we no we were not taking money out
of trigonometry at this point but people
were starting to give us money
and the money that we were paying ant on
the generous 500 quid a month
was actually not coming from us anymore
for the first time no we weren't losing
money doing
no i think we still work actually no
because then there was there was other
costs oh yeah there was other yeah but
then what happened is a couple of people
came in one of them uh
who who messaged us saying guys
i love what you do
i want to support you
and i think that the subtext was your
show looks and sounds [ __ ] what can i do
yeah and he bought us um
cameras he bought his new cameras what
about microphones did he buy microphones
as well no cameras it was just cameras
right it was just cameras
and i think we ourselves put more money
into it and bought lapel mics for the
first time as well not these ones
because these are much better no no yeah
they they were they were massive
yeah
and we got those
and then we started recording
at the new space
right yeah
and then and and that's where we got you
know we made progress that's where we
got douglas yeah eventually for a second
time yep right uh we had a lot of upbeat
peter hitchens peter hitchens yeah we
got hitch in there we got whoever
starkey
yeah we we had starkey in there we had
zooby zooby
fleischmann again anaya yeah
uh jeffrey miller jeffrey who was great
yeah well we did a lot mike martin like
a lot of our great interviews were done
in that and ella hill yeah that was a
brilliant that is i i i don't know what
other interviews were going to do i
suspect
i that would be one of interviewing ella
in that way
will be one of the most
things that i'm most proud of in my life
decades from now yeah decades from now
i mean
ella is brilliant is an important
subject that no one wanted to talk about
and we interviewed the survivor
of a group of
mass rape basically yeah
and it was funny yeah
like i i'm so proud of that yeah it's
it's an incredible interview it's an
incredible interview
and that period where it was between the
lockdowns
where we came out and we did in-person
interviews that was a very special time
we interviewed lawrence again
i think that's on something ridiculous
like half a million views yeah and the
first time we interviewed lawrence as
well and lawrence has gone in his own
direction since but at the time it was a
it was a great moment yeah it was it was
a great moment it was people were
reaching out to us saying oh i love your
show and these are like people that we
would you know respect yeah so and we
interviewed lawrence
are you sure it can be it was it was a
brilliant time and
still to contextualize it
you you were still teaching yeah you
were still doing overnight radio you
were i think no at this point because
this was we were we haven't even touched
on lockdown yeah well we haven't got to
log down yet hold on yeah yeah so
lock down so before lockdown you were
still teaching yeah i was still teaching
one day a week yeah i wasn't doing the
radio anymore i'd quit the radio at that
point
but i was still teaching and gigging six
nights ago and i was cooking six nights
right and i was
the thing i talked about with jeff it
was during that period yeah record two
interviews drive to another city do a
gig wake up the next day drive to
another city do a gig drive back to
london wake up after five hours sleep go
to the battle of ideas all day there go
to bed wake up next day gig yeah yeah
that and that that was brutal yeah that
was the treadmill that we were on
that was absolutely brutal that's what
we were doing and then
covered here yeah
i remember when covered here i was at
the top secret comedy club probably the
best comedy club in in in the uk love it
to pieces and i and i was uh doing it
and i was emceeing a gig
and it i think it was on monday i can't
remember the exact day i think it was
the 31st of march but someone will
probably correct me on when it was
and boris johnson had just told everyone
to go home to literally go home the
society was shutting down and it was the
last gig
that we i was i was there
and um the gig carried on because the
next day it was done
and uh
the i remember the mc didn't turn up
because she couldn't get an uber
so i effectively closed the gig myself
so i emceed it and then i did 20 minutes
at the end to close a gig
and it was just it felt like end of days
and i remember there were this lovely
sweet old couple who came to watch the
gig and afterwards they
walked past me and they were like we
really enjoyed this and i remember
thinking to myself what are you doing
here
what are you doing here this this is
dangerous legitimately dangerous what
you're doing
why are you here
and it was weird there was just an air
of
terror in the room but also a feeling of
we need to be here because we don't know
when we're going to be able to do this
again
and it was a very very bizarre time
well how is that for you
well i you know i've been proven right
on it i said it's just a bit of flute
i mean that was my attitude look at the
two of us i think i'm much more risk uh
hungry and you're much more risk averse
yeah so you you've been proven right
over the last couple of years but again
to emphasize when locked down here
this
we
hadn't taken any money
for us
in any way we still were putting our own
money into it the only thing was
that was the thing that really was
horrible about lockdown what happened
was
we had just got our first big sponsor
yeah which was qt if you remember
advertising qt and they agreed to pay us
an amount which meant that we could
increase anton's salary yeah and for the
first time in the history of the show
yeah
nearly two years
after we
started
we could actually take a little bit of
money yeah for ourselves i was so
thrilled at that and i remember
in early april just before lockdown i
sent my second our second invoice
to qt to our sponsor to get the second
batch of money and he wrote back saying
i've just laid off half my team i'm
sorry i can't see this through
so having just started to get to a point
where actually we could afford to do
this full-time because it's not about
putting money in the bank it was about
allowing us just to do this right that
was what we needed the money for
and it's gone
and lockdown's hit
and the comedy club where we were
recording said you can't record yeah and
you remember people were very very
scared about covered at the time of
course understandably understandably so
so
no guest would come in
and we had to do everything remotely
yeah right
i remember
being locked
being in my flat
and going from gigging six nights a week
working working working to build this
career to build relationships to get to
the point where i was constantly working
where i was earning
okay money for the first time in my life
okay money
i'm not talking big money i'm talking
okay money
and overnight
it was gone
and we were making i was at that point i
was making 500 quid a month from
trigonometry
i'd quit my teaching job yeah and i was
living on 500 quid a month yeah
which didn't cover rent yeah which
didn't cover bills yeah which didn't
cover food yeah we didn't cover any of
that yeah and i remember looking around
the four walls of my little flat
in the harren game going
i'm [ __ ]
i can't go go back to teaching
that's done
stand-up's finished possibly forever is
this the start of a new world where
this virus spreads everywhere and is
deadly and what what are we gonna do
and i just remember just being
overwhelmed by the sense of complete
hopelessness and i remember
sinking into a feeling of despair and
that's when you decided to break up with
your girlfriend yeah
yeah
and then yeah and then
you know and there was a number of
things in my life that didn't work and
we we broke up and it
it was it was a right thing for both of
us
but
but just
looking around and realizing that
everything had changed and i remember
comedians going oh this is only going to
be two or three weeks
and i knew it everything had changed
i remember being in bed one day
and going
and this was early april
and going no this is this is permanent
because the way i saw it there were only
three ways out of this either we had a
vaccine that would have been at that
point no vaccine against a coronavirus
or
uh
what happens is the virus is not as
potent as we thought and at that time it
got into the care homes and it was
really bad at the time yeah and
thousands of people were dying every
week from it and i was like well that's
not going to happen
or the government are just going to let
it rip
and that wasn't going to happen either
so
and then you remember boris johnson got
very ill with it and was hospitalized
and then that's when i was thinking now
this is yeah
this this is
really serious
and everything has changed
and i remember talking to a friend of
mine who made the point that
what we're going to have now is it's
going to be like aids there was a
pre-age world and there's a post-aids
world
and that's what it was going to be like
with covert there's going to be
pre-covered and post-covered and that's
the way it is and that's what's proven
to be well here's the thing with
lockdown and covet is
for all the terrible stuff that we you
know we've talked about it on the show a
lot um
i think it's fair to say
that covid
saved us yeah and made us yeah
i can tell you covert saved my marriage
for example yeah if i had continued
working in that way that we were just
talking about
it was going downhill rapidly because i
just wasn't i wasn't spending any time
with my wife because i just didn't have
any energy to do it and emotionally i
wasn't there i wasn't present because i
was constantly on my way somewhere on my
way you know we were we were sitting
last night just talking and i remembered
driving home from from a gig
and i literally
felt that i had so little time i got an
empty water bottle and i i peed into it
while driving on the motorway do you
know how [ __ ] dangerous that is
depends how big your dick is i suppose
well not for me but yeah
but no yeah yeah but it's also a
reflection of a state of mind i just
couldn't fit it anyway
it's a reflection of a state of mind and
it's a reflection of where you are and
you're not you're not a good partner no
to anyone in that situation
i'm frankly when i think back to her i'm
amazed
like we've we held this together we held
our relationship well no in your case
but you know
um
it was really really tough and the fact
that lockdown happened and
hey you know you want a gig well you
can't yeah you want to do this you can't
yeah so you might as well
do a uh what we started doing which is
live streams which we've been doing like
once a week up to that point and even
then sporadically sporadically and we
just look we just went look we've got
nothing else to do let's do two
interviews a week
and let's do live streams
and then we got anton on board with the
live streams over time as well and it
just became a thing that people and now
we call them raw trigonometry raw it's a
separate show
which will probably go further and
further in its own direction over time
while the interviews go for and we'll
talk about that uh later on
um you know
and that was a huge moment for us and
that was the first time when we actually
started to make enough money to cover
our costs and so that we could do this
full-time yeah yeah and even then there
was a perception in the industry that we
were making a lot of money at that point
we were no no no we
we were paying i think
we went from paying anton 500 quid to
paying him a thousand quid a month for
full-time work yeah he was full-time
yeah he was insane i remember literally
sitting down right before lockdown
because at this point we were already
thinking we need to go full-time
we were in a steak restaurant ironically
yeah with anton being a vegetarian and i
remember saying i mean it's ridiculous
and we laugh about it saying this now i
said to him anton what is the least
amount of money we need to pay you to do
this yeah
because that's the situation yeah we
needed to take it full time but we
couldn't afford to yeah and anton came
up with some ridiculous figure like a
thousand pounds which you can't live off
in central london no right that doesn't
even cover rain no but that was that was
the moment
when
we sort of went okay we're doing this
yeah we're doing this and actually my
second appearance of good morning
britain i'm very pleased with because it
ties into the story of anton joining us
because he was doing part-time work at
the time
and i just did this thing with uh what's
his face adil ray
and um
dr schola
and where i mean
you know they got wrecked yeah they got
absolutely wrecked by what i'd said and
it was really good and i was calm and i
was measured and i was funny and i was
playful but i absolutely destroyed them
right
and i sent a message to anton saying
anton i think we need to make a video of
this this was like what in the morning
first thing yes 8 a.m and anton had just
got to work yeah and he'd got in and
apparently this is the story that he
always loves to tell which is hilarious
he gets in he sits down at his desk he
gets the message from me having just
like made a coffee for himself and i go
anton we've got this thing that if we
put it out it could go viral
and he goes back to his desk picks up
all his [ __ ] at his job and just walks
out and he goes i'll be back
and he didn't come back that day and i
think that's kind of when you knew you
were all in right um
and then locked down and then that's
when the show really took off yeah and
the show took off overlooked locked the
first lockdown the first lockdown and
the thing that really
meant that we could really take our foot
and put our foot on the gas was that we
embraced remote interviews because
before then we'd been like remote
interviews were crap and they're not as
good as in person and we know that to be
the case they're not as good as in
person that's just the simple truth of
it
but every interview was a romantic
interview no one was doing in person so
all of a sudden
you could do a remote interview and then
we got some really big guests scott
adams came on
we got
we got some huge people on
and uh that and you know deborah so
deborah came on all these people that
we've been watching on rogan and reuben
all of a sudden were appearing on our
show and it was really really really
exciting for us yeah for us not for them
but but what i also mean is
the reason i bring it up is when the
first lockdown it only lasted a couple
of months but it radically transformed
the show yeah it meant that we all went
full-time at this point again not making
much money but we had enough money just
to make just to not have to do other
things that's all it was yeah right just
just so we could not have to do other
things and that's the point of which we
went back to the comedy club right as
the first lockdown finished
and we interviewed lawrence fox again
and we interviewed zubie this was the
blm you know hyped situation aisha camby
inaudiban a lot of people who were
critical of this movement uh and we and
we were frankly at this point we were
like okay we know what we're doing yeah
we know what we believe we know who we
want to talk to and we don't really care
what other people think about it yeah
and so and so we and so that and that
was a really really exciting moment
because
we could you could feel that you know
that everything was really starting to
motor and do really well
and then
we got asked to leave yeah we were asked
to leave for a variety of different
reasons and
look the reason why you you feel
hesitant to talk about it is that
the club and the people there have done
us
a lot of good things yeah and we will
always be eternally grateful to them for
doing that
but also the way we left
was unpleasant yeah and i think it was
unfair yeah right yeah um and i think we
got kicked out of there due to a
combination of political differences
which we always knew were going to be
the case
a little bit of jealousy a little bit of
just locked down sending everybody
mental yeah but it was very unpleasant
yeah it was especially for you yeah it
was just because these were your friends
yeah because it was unpleasant it was
unpleasant for me
and and then i remember thinking that
we went in we recorded it and we had to
leave
and just feeling this sense of
devastation feeling a sense of shock
feeling a sense of
bereavement almost because it had been a
community
so that happened so i was thinking to
myself right well just imagine this for
people watching hold on before you say
how you like
we've just got to a point yeah just got
to a point where we can actually we're
not making money yeah
and and i keep mentioning money not
because i'm jewish but just because it's
what makes any anything work you need
money to make things work right we just
started making enough money to pay
everybody
just enough to cover their basic costs
so we could do this full-time and make
it what it needs to be
we're just we've got these big guests
the show's exploding it's growing yeah
and now we've lost our studio again yeah
in the middle of a [ __ ] pandemic and
lockdown yeah so we've lost our studio
we've lost everything
i then get a call from my landlady going
we're gonna need you to leave the flat
so i i not only that i lost my flat
and then i remember just
just looking around going right they've
taken
my career is gone
i'm no longer at the comedy club that i
used to be my relationship has ended and
they turned into flat i can't live in my
flat anymore well you got left as me
yeah and that's depressing and i'm
thinking anything else yeah anything
else yeah and just and going right and
then i moved in with a friend who as a
stop gap and and then i just i remember
calling you up and going look i think
i've got an idea
i've got an idea you weren't like well
what is it what's the solution go look
why don't we rent a flat in london we
run a flat
for myself and anton
and we just turn the living room into a
studio
and then when it's not a studio we'll
put everything away and it becomes a
living room and that way we're not
beholden to people that way we don't
have to ask the people that way we're
not dependent on favors the all of these
different things
all of these different things yeah and
so
after a few weeks of non-stop looking
you worked really hard you found a place
we moved in
we got it designed yeah the way we
wanted we threw basically all the money
we had at it yeah because we just knew
it needed to be right same same as my
approach has always been it needs to
look good and needs to sound good yeah
and it needs to be a good experience for
the guest
and
i remember the first we got these chairs
that we're sitting in now and the first
time we walked into that studio we sat
down
douglas murray sat down across from us
and i just
for the first time i just thought
wow
i have the freedom to ask this great man
who i respect so much
who we are becoming
closer and familiar with anything i want
yeah i don't have to worry about some
woke comedian behind that door right
there in this tiny room
you know overhearing me ask the wrong
question or whatever i can just
say what i think and ask him what he
thinks
and we can have a conversation and
that's when the drilling started and
that's when the training started
yeah yeah that's when the drilling
started because there's a there's a you
know
doing the show in a residential space
it's difficult it's going to cause
challenges but nonetheless that was a
brilliant first interview with it was
we had some issues with the sound which
we we ended up getting around
and then it it just i think it
steamrolled from there
and then we started doing raw together
we used to do it remotely or in my
little office at home or whatever we
started doing it properly with the good
cameras with the right equipment
streaming live four nights a week
uh and
and that's kind of where it went and
went and went
to the point where
for the first time we actually didn't
get kicked out of the studio yeah we
moved ourselves yeah
yep because what happened was
the flat was great it was lovely but the
reality is we'd outgrown it yeah and
also you know when we talk people think
we're super successful and rich and
whatever which we're really not like at
the last studio like two months ago
we would record the interview in the
very room where i would sleep on the
sofa yeah you were literally sleeping i
was sleeping on this i remember saying
to one on one of our calls because we do
these monthly calls with our uh top
supporters
uh from locals and patreon and subscribe
star etc
and i remember saying you know i was
sleeping on the sofa and one of them
laughed
he laughed like he was like a joke a
joke
but two months ago that's what it was
yeah anton had his little room which was
packed with all our equipment you could
barely walk around it you had your
little room yeah and then the living
room i would sleep in yeah you know and
it was like a studio and it looked like
a studio it looked like a studio with
two bedrooms attached to it yeah and
when we wanted to have lunch initially
we ate our food off little stools
then we got like a portable table that
we would put up and then have to get rid
of just to have enough space in the
studio to put the equipment in do you
know what i used to do actually antoine
i'm sorry about this i shouldn't admit
this every time anton went out on a date
i made sure that i put just a picture of
lawrence fox on his bed just when he
came in
you're such a [ __ ]
you always have been haven't you yeah
just bring it just bring back
oh you know this is sorry about my
techniques
it was bad enough his room was filled
with like lights and studio equipment
do you remember that not just going back
for a second the anton used to carry the
entire studio on his back yeah yeah in a
previous studio because we couldn't
leave anything there we had to just he
would get all this and he would be this
massive bag on his back yeah and then
two little suitcases yeah like a tech
turtle yeah
turning up and then just unloading and
then so finally we were like okay look
we got a bit of a nudge in that they
were doing massive renovation at the old
place not only
not only in in the building but also in
the road they literally digging up the
entire road yeah so i was having to
negotiate with polish builders who could
not give less of a [ __ ] yeah but also it
was an incredibly rough council estate
in east london do you remember when tim
stanley tim stanley came in we
interviewed him he was all great and
then he walked out and we just heard
like a mental homeless man assaulting
him outside well no yeah but not yet but
shouting yeah no not literacy
yeah it's just
tim stanley trying to get away yeah and
then well first day we moved in there
you nearly got mugged yeah it did and
then some guy came up to to my wife and
said oh do you want to come with me i'm
a nice clean boy
so it was a rough council it was not the
greatest place to you know like i
remember waiting outside for douglas
murray just in walking paths looking
around yeah but anyway so and now
we've moved to this place where we can
have this beautifully designed set
for the main interviews yeah and a
separate set for raw that we're still
working on that's going to be different
to what it's been
so far
and
i think we should talk about i know
we've gone for quite a long time but i
think we should talk about
where we're going with the show and one
of the things that i think we were
really keen to do
you know is to bring the idea of honest
conversations with fascinating people
more and more
to the forefront of what we do because i
think as the show has evolved initially
you know the name trigonometry a lot of
people are very confused about why we
called it that you know i think a lot of
people think it's about triggering the
libs or whatever
people talk about actually it was very
much in many ways a trigger warning he
was saying look we're going to try and
have an honest conversation about
difficult subjects and you might find
this offensive that it was sort of a
defense mechanism almost and look we've
got to let's be honest as well we were
all so angry yeah we were we were angry
i was angry at being in a in an industry
where i felt misrepresented i think we
both did speak you can speak for
yourself but i've certainly felt
misrepresented
condescended looked down upon sneered at
all of these things just because i
thought differently
and i was [ __ ] done
so there was a part of trigonometry
which was [ __ ] you at least 100 100 and
i was the same especially after that
contract
especially after i realized that
actually
these other people in comedy who i
thought
idealistically admittedly were
this was my team
and they were liberal which they're not
yeah in the old school sense and they're
not liberal they're authoritarians no
they're authoritarians who want to shut
people up they want to shut down
discussion they definitely don't want
you to be allowed to have your opinion
and and and by the way they hate you for
being successful yeah they hate you for
being successful yeah you know um
so there was a big part of it that was
there was that [ __ ] you initially and i
think you and i have moved on quite a
lot so yes we don't feel that way and
that's why
i think the slogan of honest
conversations with fascinating people is
in many ways much more representative of
the future direction of trigonometry
than the word trigonometry yeah you know
so you people will see more of that i
think coming in uh and eventually that
may even end up being the name of the
show yeah
i think trigonometry the show and the
the title of the show has been brilliant
and it summed up a moment but that
moment was very much you know 2018 2019
2020.
i think as we want to be moving on what
we want to do
we've always strived to do this which is
bring you know
people from the left people who we might
who we disagree with
but we want it to be
a more open place for these people to
come but see i mean you say that people
from the left people we disagree with we
just interviewed will store who's on the
left did we disagree with him no no no
no no do you know what i mean yeah like
so i think we shouldn't put ourselves in
this trap i don't think we disagree with
people on the left
you are off the left i am very open to a
large number of important ideas that the
left focuses on
i just think we're not on board with
this work nonsense okay so progressivism
yeah we're not on i'm not on board with
progress i'm not on board with
pretending that things are true that
aren't true you know and that's all i've
ever cared about our the thing that
unites us more than anything is
intellectual curiosity yeah and we want
to get to the truth no matter which side
it's on yeah right which to me is why
the slogan is much more representative
of who we are now than the word
trigonometry yeah and also as well
because emotionally i'm not
i'm not angry no like i used to be i
don't feel
frustrated i don't feel unheard i don't
it would be incredibly hypocritical and
duplicitous of me to claim any of these
emotions when the reality is that none
of that applies anymore
and trigonometry came from
us
being in that space feeling those things
it was a kickback it had its elements in
punk and all the rest of it and that's
why when the logo was designed it had
those things
actually woven into it but i think now
as we move on we want to move past that
yeah we want to actually
broaden even more the conversation yeah
we want to talk to a wider range of
voices
well look this is something you and i've
always actually been really interested
in if you think about the three of us
and our favorite episodes
they're not really
there we've done some great episodes
that are you know
woke idiots this and work because they
are idiots and they're dangerous idiots
and and we'll continue to point that out
because i think it's important i think
it's important to defend
you know
civil
liberties and western enlightenment
values they need to be defended and if
they're not defended
this world will change in a bad way i i
feel very strongly that's why you know
in my book this is what i talk about
that's why it's called an immigrant's
love letter to the west it's very
important to protect and preserve these
things but in addition to that look at
our favorite interviews there with
evolutionary biologists with scientists
with people who can explain a lot about
what's happening in society not in terms
of the culture war
but actually just in terms of how people
behave how human beings are wired why
they do what they do
and so
that's what i've always seen the future
of the show as you know a lot of people
think that we're just these culture
warriors i don't feel that way at all i
feel the great privilege of doing the
show is we get to talk to people who are
just interesting who are just successful
who who have a mindset that anyone in
their right mind would love to emulate
that have an ability to dissect you know
and and you know separate [ __ ] from
the truth and present it in an
articulate interesting way that's what
the show will be about and and i keep
saying this i don't know if it's true
but i suspect 10 15 years from now if
the show is still going which i hope it
will be and i'm sure will be
we will be pushing back against people
on the right yeah we do all the time i
mean i've just been having arguments
with people on the right who are going
too far in my opinion on this obsession
with you know conspiracy theories about
the vaccine people who say oh the
vaccine is not at all about health i'm
just going you [ __ ] mental yeah
do you know what i mean of course there
are a lot of things that have happened
in relation to covet that i think are
very suspicious and suspect but
let's not go down the rabbit hole that
far no let's not go into you know
retweeting david ike or whatever
so i'm going to be pushing back i think
against all the people who i just think
are just wrong yeah
yeah you know and if they're on the
right we'll push back against them and
if they're on the left we'll push
against them and but it's like anything
once you you talk about a subject too
much it becomes hack
in order to use a comedy term we
you know and it becomes boring and
stayed and a lot of what we were talking
about in 2018 has now filtered into the
mainstream or is beginning to certainly
and now everybody's talking about it
but that's a sign for us as well that
there's other things to talk about now
things that are not getting addressed
let's leave it there because in the
follow-up episode to this one we're
going to talk about the actual issues
that we are interested in what's going
on in the world what we want to cover
going forward etc uh but for now that
has been the past
the present and the future of
trigonometry uh take care and we'll see
you in in a few days time with a
follow-up to this take care and see you
soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below